alors que pensez vous de ces cases par
an 1 et par an 2 je vois damien qui est
prête à bondir
damien visiblement ça ne vous satisfait
pas mais personnellement je trouve que
c'est de l'égalitarisme 2 à 2 balles en
fait parce que pourquoi parce qu en fait
être papa ou maman pour certains députés
en fait c'est devenu has been en fait
c'est un gros mot de dire on n'est pas
pas où on est maman
et puis cette mesure moi je la trouve
extrêmement discriminatoire pourquoi par
exemple à partir du moment où vous dites
parents ou parents 2 qui est le parent
qui est le parent 2 moi personnellement
je n'ai pas être j'ai pas envie d'être
le parent de maître que vous estimez
quand il ya une hiérarchie entre le
singe et le deuil effectivement ça
impose une certaine hiérarchie parentale
et puis le deuxième argument qui n'est
pas des moindres pour moi c'est que
cette déshumanise terriblement le père
ou la mère enfin pardonnez moi
simplement vous savez que d'ores et déjà
il existe des formulaires que moi par
exemple j'ai rempli pour mon fils où il
ya marqué représentant légal de cinq
panneaux représentant légal ne fait pas
normal c'est pas normal parce que ça
sous-entend qu'en tant que maire vous
êtes une entité administrative voilà
vous vous n'êtes ni plus ni moins que
d'un représentant légal nord vous êtes
la mer et ça c'est important de le
souligner je remercie parce que j'avais
un doute est là maintenant comme le
disent les ans mais je comprends ce que
vous voulez dire mais visiblement à vos
côtés il est quand même par belinda
d'aquagym notre petit damien je pense
que ton rôle de père ne se définit pas
une case que tu vas cocher ou non dans
un formulaire pour ton enfant à l'école
après moi je trouve ça très bien qu'on
essaye de faire en sorte que les
familles homoparentales soir le
présentait aussi parce que pour les
enfants c'est très important aussi ça se
faire parce qu'ils sont déjà pleins de
fin assez plein la tête
donc c'est bien aussi d'alors inquiétude
supplémentaire et pour réactualiser un
petit peu ce sujet depuis la polémique
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
jean michel blanquer s'est rallié au
compromis qui était défendu par la co
rapporteur du projet de loi anne
christine langue qui propose donc des
cases repères et des cases mais
raccroché donc on pourrait cocher deux
fois de chaque côté perpère mer-mer ou
voilà qu'est ce que vous en pensez
caroline ce serait beaucoup plus logique
je rejoins un tout petit peu mon
camarade damien même si à chaque fois
que j star
j'ai peur de des traces on a quatre
matches là même si je trouve très sympa
et le droit national
le problème c'est que l'intention est
bonne ce qui vous chagrine est donc dans
parents apparent de la même chose que
damien traille est vrai que je trouve
que le le numéro 1 maintenant mais parce
que moi je suis je suis pour qu'on mette
un parent 3 par an
vous étiez très open beaucoup battu 13
open mais allons-y franchement dans ces
cas là l'intention est bonne il ya de
plus en plus de familles homoparentales
le gouvernement s'en rend compte et
c'est le rôle de l'éducation de intégrer
les raves avec la génération qui arrive
et de vivre avec son époque maintenant
c'est très maladroit par an un parent 2
c'est vrai que deux numérotés comme ça
les parents ont donc voulu être le
nouvel amendement qui va être proposé en
quelques semaines avec une kazuya
permettre une case où il ya les uns
viennent même leur mère ça vous convient
non mais c'est un numéro d' hypocrites
là que j'entends la de vous deux mais
alors c'est incroyable comme si vous
n'aviez pas compris le sens de cette
mesure le sens de cette nature récemment
je me suis dit alors le sens de cette
mesure c'est simplement d'éviter la
douleur des gosses qui pourrait souffrir
d'avoir deux papas ou deux mamans est
donc d'essayer d'égaliser deux justement
ne pas discriminer
je suis vraiment désolé mais le livret
de famille comme le ganga scolaire tu
dors pas avec toutes les nuits en le
regardant les autres qui est papa qui
est maman mais il est ridicule cet
argument en gros c'est cacher cette
différence que je ne saurais voir enfin
moment donné le fils il sort à un moment
donné qu'il a deux par an et il va
devoir le dire là jusqu'au bout de ton
raisonnement ce que tu supportes pas en
réalité c'est le fait que des enfants et
de papas ou deux mamans je fais de poser
un temps parce que derrière toute cette
polémique c'est tout ça qui se cache
finalement donc fallait pas l'accepter
au départ caroline ah ben je suis pas du
tout d'accord avec jean michel moi par
exemple c'est pas du tout ça le qui me
posent le problème et je sais pas si
c'est le cas pour damien est en tout cas
moi c'est pas le fait qu' un enfant et
deux papas ou deux mamans que vous
voulez qu'on mette les noms c'est à dire
que ye papa et papa maman maman obama et
maman la même score 2 3 4 etc
je trouve que c'est important
effectivement que l'école aujourd'hui il
ya plein d'école où il ya plus de fête
des pères fête des mères je trouve ça
très bien c'est vrai qu'il ya des
enfants qui sont aussi orphelin michel à
l'envers ce serait pas peut-être aussi
un peu tarte us de dire parents apparent
de est-ce qu'on pourrait pas tout
simplement dire sur les scolaires par an
papa et papa maman et maman que seul
argument que j'ai reçu c'est l'argument
de l'ordre prioritaire selon damien par
un parent 2 mais très franchement il ya
plein de situations où par exemple dans
un bulletin de ministres hâtives on
remplit monsieur d'abord où madame
d'abord et c'est en fait un argument
j'ai moi je dis qu'il ya beaucoup
d'hypocrisie derrière je me sens ce qui
s'est passé c'est que ne voulant pas
choquer certains y compris la manif pour
tous ils ont mis par an un parent 2 pour
éviter de ma vie au volant
papa de papa et de maman est en fait
d'une bonne intention se retrouvent
car un débat qui excusez moi mais
complètement puéril parce que moi je
trouve pas que d'écrire que je suis
parent 1 où je suis parent 2 ça va faire
en sorte que mon enfant mais on aura un
peu moins que montrent que le paraguay
ou quoi c'est juste que tant de mal
quand même
on va poser enfin on a posé la question
de téléspectateurs cette polémique
autour des cases par an un parent de
est-ce que vous la comprenez vous ne la
comprenait pas et ne la comprennent pas
à 60% ils la comprennent à 40
donc visiblement tu ne posais pas de
souci là pour nos téléspectateurs en
tout cas pour 60% d'entre eux papa maman
parents parents d'appelés vous comme
vous voulez mais laisser leurs loisirs
aux enfants
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]